ماركوس جونيور الرئيس الفلبيني منذ ايام
قليله يراقب مناورات عسكريه مشتركه بين
جيش بلاده والقوات الامريكيه المتمركزه في
الفلبين
ماركوس الذي سمحت حكومته للولايات المتحده
بزياده قواعدها العسكريه في الفلبين الى
تسع قواعد الشهر الماضي قال انه لن يسمح
ان تصبح بلاده منطلقا لاي حرب ضد اي دوله
في اشاره واضحه الى الصين
جاء هذا التصريح في الوقت الذي تزايدت
الحوادث بين خفر السواحل الصيني والفلبيني
في بحر الصين الجنوبي الممر التجاري
الدولي الحيوي بالنسبه لبكين والذي تقول
انه خاضع لسيادتها الامر الذي يلقى رفضا
في واشنطن ومانيلا وغيرهما من عواصم
المنطقه
تكمن اهميه بحر الصين الجنوبي وخاصه مضيقا
ملقا للاقتصاد الصيني في كونه ممرا يحمل
ثلث حجم التجاره العالميه ولذلك تريد بكين
فرض سيطرتها عليه بنشر موانئ وقواعد
عسكريه لتسيطر عليه وخاصه انه الطريق
البحري الوحيد الذي تستورد الصين عبره كل
مواردها من الطاقه
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه من جانبها نبهت
الصين الى ان اي هجوم على الفلبين سيستوجب
ردا عسكريا امريكيا حسب الاتفاقيات
العسكريه التي وقعتها واشنطن ومن لا
دعوات لتهدئه ولغه دبلوماسيه تعززها
مناورات عسكريه ينظمها البلدان بشكل منتظم
احداثها ستنطلق في الاول من مايو بمشاركه
طائرات مقاتله من البلدين في رساله واضحه
للصين ان لا اعتراف بسيادتها على بحر
الصين الجنوبي
انس النماسي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات